[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week
boy do we have some boneheads um they
start to appear here um
yesterday the select uh hearing happened
so that's where our poll came from but
this morning there appeared some more
boneheads obviously
but everyone voted on these three
boneheads jeffrey clark that name is
starting to emerge of that america knows
who that person is now and what his role
in trying to overthrow our government
and his role in the cheeto dust kangaroo
ku was we also have the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy pants himself
donald trump on this on this pole and
then drunk rudy grandpa farty mcarty
giuliani now also on the pole here i
mean
can you go back to that photo let's just
look at these three the the three
stooges right here is what i was like
you know it's just amazing
how well these people play together in
terms of trying to ruin the country you
know or at least attempting to ruin the
country it's insane what we what we what
we witnessed yesterday oh yeah i mean
even as the testimony came out even
during the fourth hearing right like we
talked about this after yesterday's
hearing but there's like if there was a
theme for the fourth one it was showing
how terrible a person donald trump is on
a human level as well as rudy giuliani
and the extent they would go to ruin
people's lives right you have the poll
workers and her and the poll worker and
her mother they came up and they told
their story which was very very
compelling and very moving
and the fact that these people were like
oh yeah let me just ruin this person's
reputation everything they have in terms
of their livelihood and everything they
have going on in their life and claim
and and defame this person that they
were you know
cheating and doing drugs and doing this
doing that and then you find out
yesterday you're like oh hold on now
we're going to show how trump and
jeffrey clark tried to
hand their individually tried to to uh
overturn the election and plan this coup
almost on their own
with these other people being like what
the [ __ ] is going on that that was some
of the most groundbreaking stuff
yesterday when they started to
because they were talking about the lead
up to january 6th right a lot like where
those components worked right who
jeffrey clark was like where he came
from the thing that i was like holy
actual [ __ ] was when the the
dudes that sat in the meeting where
donald trump is trying to appoint
jeffrey clark to be the attorney general
so he can declare
that donald trump is the president
because that's
literally he just wanted someone anyone
to say that he was the president yeah
he's like can i get some sort of
confirmation bias here from anyone right
he was looking for the attorney general
then the vice president i mean this list
goes on and on he's like oh there's the
there's the italian satellites that are
changing the records like exactly the
absolute [ __ ] i mean there's the there's
the quote that i am sure was going to
live forever which is you guys don't
know how the internet works basically
where he said like i don't think you
guys know how the internet works uh like
the way that i i yeah i i know how the
internet works better than you do or
something like that and it's crazy it's
i mean many many quotes have come out of
this thing rudy giuliani is saying like
we didn't have the evidence so we just
pursued it anyway
right all of these guys and you had
they're given a testimony you had
donahue you had rosen you had angle and
they were both like yeah we all came in
on that day in street [ __ ] clothes to
handle this meeting because trump was
trying to tell us how uh jeffrey clark
who was a subordinate was going to fire
rosen
and then be his boss and then
i think the funniest part of this and
like the [ __ ] goal that jeffrey clark
has is like yeah well i'll keep you on
just like for like special stuff if you
want to stay and rosen is like
[ __ ] no well rosen was like who the [ __ ]
are you right who the [ __ ] are you i
don't know where you are i know they
were like well because they've been
brought up they're like you don't
actually have any justification to be
talking about what you're talking about
he's like well i mean you know i've done
this he's like we haven't actually
defended a case you haven't brought
anything on a on a high level before and
he's like well i've done some
environmental stuff and i think it was
donahue who said
you know in so many words said shut the
[ __ ] up and go back to your office and
when we have an oil spill we'll call you
right right that was incredible what the
thing the thing that was
that shows really who trump is
is when is when donahue is describing
that they
between
donahue rosen and angle the three
witnesses yesterday in the room and they
basically said hey look we've already
contacted all the department of justice
there's gonna be mass [ __ ]
resignations you're not even going to
have a department of justice
for him to be the attorney general of
yeah
in the final 20 days of his presidency
right right well and when when they're
describing it to him trump finally
finally comes to his senses and realizes
that it will be worse for him if he
if he does this than better for him
right right he finally he finally has
some common sense talked into him at
that moment
and his first reaction when he says okay
i'm not gonna make him the attorney
general meaning jeffrey clark he turns
to donahue
and he says now what are you going to do
about him and he points it down to you
and points at clark and says because he
at the in that moment
donald trump wants so bad for some
because he's a reality tv buffoon
he wants donahue to lean across the
table as if this is the apprentice and
go you're fired like he literally or
even worse like he's imagining he's like
if he was a mob boss he's not going to
do the hit he's going to have someone
else doing it for him so he's like what
are you going to do for me right but but
donnie's like well i'm not going to do
anything he's like why not he's like i
can't do anything he's a senate
confirmed department of justice official
right i can't do anything about him he's
like i'm also the deputy so i can't even
right below him right but that's the but
that's the thing is that it just
it just makes it more of the of what the
mindset of donald trump is that he does
not understand and he even even up until
the final three weeks of his presidency
he still hadn't figured out that we the
people choose a president the president
gets to nominate nominees for these
offices and we the people choose the
senate and the senate under our
our jurisdiction and our vote gets to
confirm those people to be a part of the
government he still does not understand
how democracy works why we are democracy
he really does think the power of the
presidency is a dictatorship he really
truly believes that the office of the
presidency is an authoritarian figure he
does not understand it he's a [ __ ]
idiot he doesn't understand the actual
power that he had and that's probably
why he's the bone in
on the bone end of the week right here
you see the vote folks on twitter the
poll jeffrey clark got almost 50
now gabe did this this same reflection
happened on youtube was it no it was
actually we've been getting this we've
been getting this a lot where the the
youtube first the first few times we ran
the poll on youtube and twitter we were
finding that they were pretty much in
line with each other and i almost just
had us i was like oh my god did i run
the poll wrong because i remember who
won and i was like wait is this who
actually did it and then in fact
the youtube
outcome results
or uh you know in ways overturned
what the results were on twitter and
flipped
because we we have two different states
here that we take votes from we take one
vote from twitter and one vote and we
count your votes we are fair it is a
free fair poll and we practice democracy
here so you decide who the bone of the
week is
and as you can see here um
it looks as if jeffrey clark has one but
when you actually go to the count
someone else has one that appears
but
again like i saw that and i was like oh
shoot did i did i make the video when
that in the in the graphics wrong and
then i was like oh no okay yeah this
actually wasn't because when you know i
had to double check my i had to do a
recount on my own briefly a recount well
you know that's and that's the other
thing that was described yesterday
because we see one of these [ __ ]
boneheads rudy giuliani who was really
trying to pressure these witnesses
yesterday as he was like the [ __ ] he
was the [ __ ] attorney for trump and
all this [ __ ] and rosen who is the
acting attorney general at that time
because we know bill barr resigned
because he didn't want to be complicit
in federal crimes rosen's like do not
do not have rudy giuliani contact me any
more i'm not talking to rudy [ __ ] rudy
rudy should not be anywhere near me i do
not want rudy anywhere near me or in the
department of justice because at one
point they're trying to get mark me
rudy's trying to get mark meadows to get
rosen
to
um
mess with this evident like these
schemes these conspiracy theories that
they have and he keeps trying to push
meadows the chief of staff tries to he's
trying to keep pushing this on the rosen
and he's using kind of rudy because he
wants rosen to meet with rudy because
rudy has this evidence right and rosen's
like look i am not i don't want to
[ __ ] see rudy i don't even want to
know if he exists at this point if he's
got evidence he's like go to a [ __ ]
fbi office there's 55 of them go there
give it to the agents in the office it
will work its way to me in the
appropriate form if there is actual
substance right to this claim
of voter fraud then somebody's going to
bring it up and say hey yo you should
look at this but the fact that he then
responded like well i think it was trump
even right
but rudy was offended rudy was right
rudy was offended and then didn't he i
forget in the moment because i was i was
on a plane was it trump or rudy that was
like well can he just like bring it to
you guys can't he just like give it to
you directly right exactly but and
rosen's like no that is not how it
[ __ ] works it doesn't work and you
know what's crazy about that
the actual thought because you got to
remember who rudy giuliani is rude
giuliani isn't just any schmoe
this guy this guy was the united states
attorney
in the southern district of new york
like he was the bee's knees of federal
prosecutors in this country
he ran basically the department of
justice 2.0 mm-hmm so he understands how
evidence works he understands how the
fbi he was in the department of justice
he's not an idiot he's been through the
process wow well okay yeah very okay he
may he he may have drank a few of his
brain cells away i mean since since
leaving office as official mayor and his
is his role as uh uh you know southern
district like he has definitely
gone down in terms of uh
quality you know in both the hair dye
and
his just sanity right and his assumption
that man you know what i just give you
this stuff and you guys should do it
right like i'm rudy i'm rudy give me it
you know
but rudy giuliani
has become nothing other or nothing more
than
a drunken
harassing troll
that we definitely witnessed on during
the fourth hearing this week where he
was just spreading lies about people and
and trying to get what he wanted to do
like well we have tons of evidence and
they're like okay
show us the evidence
right raffensberger was like you got the
evidence you got the evidence like does
anyone have the [ __ ] evidence right
you're talking about um
rusty bauer's like do you guys have the
evidence does anyone have the evidence
and they're like well yeah we have the
evidence well we have theories but we
don't want to give it anything
yeah so we don't we don't actually have
the evidence but we're gonna we're
working on theory right now and it's
like oh my [ __ ] god they're like you
guys gotta have something
at least like fabricate something give
me something that i can like go forward
with not just like well it's a bit of a
gut instinct
but i'm pretty sure joe biden cheated
and it's like well if you don't have
proof then he didn't cheat right there's
not widespread voter fraud everyone else
is telling you guys that there's no
widespread voter fraud why don't you
listen the [ __ ] up
and realize the reality that's there but
again these guys are having a rager
that party is the is the united states
and they don't want to let it go they
don't want to they don't want to go go
go you know close down and we we we
we witnessed this yesterday as these
these three acting people well one of
them is not acting uh steven engel was
in his official position right but
donahue and rosen were acting because
bill barr resigned so they had to step
up and be acting but even even the fact
that jeffrey clark
again was looking for any reason without
evidence it doesn't matter because he
was apparently doing his own
investigations in the [ __ ] that wasn't
real and there's a video
there's a video from um this character
um
eric hirschman who is eric
keeps [ __ ] breaking him
hilarious his justice bat but he's like
yeah i was there for everything
everything went through me
he just has no [ __ ] to give like he he
does not care and you can tell rosen's a
no [ __ ] kind of personality um but watch
this video where he's i think he's i
think in this video he's talking to
clark and how he's qualified for a job
listen to this and when he finished
discussing what he planned on doing
i said good
[ __ ] assuming sorry
congratulations you just admitted your
first step or act you take as attorney
general would be committing a felony and
violating rule six city you're clearly
the right candidate for this job and
then he finished discussing what he
planned on doing
i said good
[ __ ] excuse me sorry
congratulations you just admitted your
first step you take as attorney general
would be committing a felony and
violating rule 60.
it's crazy absolutely batshit crazy that
here is eric hershman and you remember
he he's the one who told eastman go get
you a [ __ ] criminal attorney because
you're going to need it after january 6.
but this is when he's talking to clark
and clark's trying to convince him of
this nonsense that he wants to be
attorney general and hershman's like you
are a dumb son of a [ __ ] like you you
are the first thing you're going to do
as attorney general is commit a felony
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you like
it just
even people inside the trump circle were
aware that this is absolute batshit
crazy
and it just i mean you know i think some
of these people definitely had a case of
senioritis where they're like oh look
like i know you guys are kind of trying
to break the law here you know and
you're committing a felony and i'm just
gonna like give you a little warning if
you wanna go about and do it good luck
we'll see what happens i don't really
care that much i got like three weeks
left in this administration so i'm just
trying to get out and go do something
else maybe in the private sector because
this shit's [ __ ] crazy right now i
just need to go
and i think that's the other thing too a
lot of people like oh mike pence is a
hero no lola is like no mike pence is
not a [ __ ] hero okay he's a coward
he's a cuck he stood by and listened to
everyone talk about this stuff
as well as all these other people now i
am very glad they have come forward and
have given testimony but none of them
are heroes because they will in the same
breath turn around just like rusty
bowers and vote for [ __ ] trump if
he's the nominee right so i'm looking
for yeah exactly so i look at this and
i'm like look
everyone here is guilty okay the sin of
omission
means that there is guilt now whether
that's a legal guilt or whatever you
know but i think there is a sin of
omission type guilt where all of these
people were aware of what people were
trying to do and were told not to do it
and they still watch these people try to
go forward with it and they didn't say
[ __ ] until the committee said hey
we need you to give a deposition and we
need to ask these questions and we need
to give you the we need to get the
answers to figure out what the [ __ ]
happened in these last couple months of
the administration
and so again all these people i'm super
grateful they came forward to reveal the
truth of what happened and you really sh
you really do see them say like man it
was [ __ ] crazy and i i warned them
but [ __ ] i was already like halfway out
the door when this [ __ ] was happening
and that's that's kind of where they
stood i mean that's why i say senior
writers on this it's like well yeah
talking but you know you didn't really
speaking of that because
donald trump was looking for anyone to
be his jeffrey clark right anyone he
could to be his jeffrey clark
whether it was pence or jeffrey clark
himself or bill barr because here's the
scene here's a scene we have where liz
cheney is describing uh bill barr and
then we see a clip of bill barr talking
about the transition because the obvious
thing is why would the department of
justice do an investigation at all
because these are state the states run
the elections not the department of
justice so listen to this part this is
[ __ ] just a flamethrower and this is
bill barr again he's saying this behind
closed doors he wouldn't say this out in
front of publix again a [ __ ] couch
none of this stuff would come out when
he was doing a tape tour right but when
he's under oath and he knows he has the
the possibility of being
being convicted under perjury yeah then
he says the truth but listen to this the
former attorney general was asked why he
authorized the department of justice to
investigate fraud in the 2020 election
at all why not just follow the regular
course of action and let the
investigations occur much later in time
after january 6th
here's what he said
felt the responsible thing to do was to
be to be in a position uh to have a view
as to whether or not there was fraud and
frankly i think the fact that i put
myself in the position that i could say
that we had looked at this and didn't
think there was fraud
was really important to moving things
forward uh and i sort of shudder to
think what the situation would have been
if the if the position of the department
was we're not even looking at this until
after biden's in office
i'm not sure we would have had a
transition at all
so there's bill barr saying we wouldn't
even had a transition like it wouldn't
and not forget about forget about
peaceful orderly at all we wouldn't even
had one he would have just declared
himself the king at at that point i mean
now
rather this fear of of bars was
justified or not you know i don't know
in that moment right because we're not
gonna know maybe until more evidence
comes out of what the conversation the
exact conversation between barr and
trump was because there's apparently
three of them that barr
is in his notes so those are the ones
that he keeps referring back to but here
he's talking about the investigation
that the doj ordered which is very
unusual in our democracy
that donald trump pressured him to have
right donald trump pressured him into
this into this investigation
so the question was why did you start
this investigation if
if it wasn't
if it wasn't necessary because
billboard's saying if we would have done
it after it really would have caused
concern and we see that now with a lot
of people calling for uh charges to be
brought and
we see jeffrey clark himself our one of
our bonehead uh nominees here being
arrested in his pajamas on wednesday
and and being searched at his house and
apparently they took his electronic
devices um is the word that's kind of
the news that is coming down i i will
say there is a uh
there are the hearings that are
happening on after july 12th which are
gonna like present national archive
stuff so right probably the things that
he took
from
uh
the uh the white house down to
mar-a-lago so expect a video for that
coming in july
but now that jeffrey clark's house has
been [ __ ] raided
and he had all these devices taken and
you know i'm just gonna have to assume
certain things were discovered in his
home so probably expect a video for that
sometime soon well i would imagine too
that
i would imagine too that uh
besides the secret videos that you
apparently have access to
here of the inside searching of jeffrey
clark's house i would imagine that the
the the federal the federal government
has
cause
to to know what is on some of those
electronic devices and they have a
suspicion of what is on those electronic
devices um speaking of electronic
devices um our alpha cuck here appeared
in the hearing as well
now matt gatz
uh you know uh they made a fool out of
him
um when
when the evidence starts to come out
that this people were seeking pardons
gabe you have this great video called
the pardon blanket and we played it
earlier in a commercial break
i looked up today because somebody
messaged me and they're like oh man you
you know uh you were very spot-on for
this commercial
and i and i looked back on the tick tock
to see when it was posted it was october
26
2021
and that was when there was mention of
some of these pardons again
nothing had been confirmed these were
all in the rumor mill but there were
people saying like oh
gates had asked for a blanket pardon and
people like what the [ __ ] that's crazy
and this is about six months after the
whole like hey there's these sex
trafficking charges that are happening
with greenberg and him but nothing had
really come to the surface of like
actual
uh evidence for the public
and then there were
whispers of saying like oh yeah these
other people
question mark over who those people were
so i just threw a bunch of names in the
mix well i mean ones that make sense
right right right so
the alpha cucks that there are in
congress and and and bam you were almost
spot on but here's here's uh here's the
actual the the actual evidence that we
have um the on the official record from
the january six here's adam kindlinger
and this video is about four minutes
long but it plays through this thing so
let me let me pull uh some of this uh
this down here and i want to make this
big because this is some bombshell [ __ ]
game
right here about the
about the apartment so let's watch this
video and then we'll comment about the
boneheads particularly the alpha cuck
met gats on the other side five days
after the attack on the capitol
representative mo brooks sent the email
on the screen now
as you see he emailed the white house
quote pursuant to a request from matt
gates
requesting a pardon for representative
gates himself
and unnamed others
witnesses told the select committee that
the president considered offering
pardons to a wide range of individuals
connected to the president
let's listen to some of that testimony
and
with representative gates requesting a
pardon
believe so
general tone was
we may get prosecuted because we were
defensive of
you know the president's positions on
these things
a pardon
that he was discussing requesting was
as broad as you could describe from
beginning i remember from the beginning
of time up until today
for ready and all things
mentioned nixon and i said nixon's
pardon was never nearly that broad
and
are you aware of any members of congress
mr gates
hey mr brooks
i know
both advocated for
there'd be a blind department for
members involved in that meeting and a
handful of other members that weren't at
the december 21st evening
um
as the preemptive pardons
uh mr gates was personally pushing for a
pardon
and he was doing services early december
i'm not sure why
she could reach out to me
to ask if you could have a meeting with
mr meadows about receiving
[Music]
mr jordan talks about congressional
parties that he never asked me for one
there's more for an update on whether
the white house is going to pardon
members of congress
mr gomer asked for one as well
and he has some hair guys too i'm sorry
did he scratch actually
yes he did
did
[Music]
heard um she asked why not counselors
for a pardon
from
mr philbin
but
i didn't frequently
communicate
are you aware of any
conversations or communications
regarding the possibility of giving
congressman matt gates a pardon
um i know he had asked for it but i
don't know if he ever received one or
what happened with it
how do you know that congressman gates
asked for a pardon he told me
uh tell us about that
he told me it asked meadows for a pardon
were you involved in or did you witness
any conversations about the possibility
of a
blanket pardon for everyone involved in
january 6th
uh i heard that mentioned
yeah
do you know whether the president had
any conversations about potentially
pardoning any uh
family members
um
i know he had hinted at a blanket pardon
for the january 6th thing for anybody
but i think he had for all the staff and
everyone involved not with january 6 but
just before he left office i know he had
talked about that
the only reason i know to ask for a
pardon
is because you think you've committed
a crime
uh he's not wrong when does an innocent
when does an innocent person go hmm
i should probably get
a blanket part in here
for something i did wrong but i don't
know what i did wrong but i'm innocent i
just need to cover my bases well i think
it's very telling that more than one
person says that matt gatz was looking
for a blanket pardon because i think
that's really important when you look at
all the federal crimes that he's being
investigated for it was almost like matt
gatz was like you know what let's try to
overturn the government i'll get the
president to think that we've committed
crimes and then he'll give me a blanket
pardon which will who doesn't matter who
wins then i can use that pocket pardon
to then
make sure that i am i am released when
they come out and the joe greenberg case
drops and they accuse me of sex
trafficking now this goes to the
question are their pocket pardons right
that's what that's a good question
that's what the question is are
their pocket pardons i think that's the
thing that that maybe some of these
federal prosecutors are really being
cautious about so
and well here's what i mean by that
because a lot of people ask on twitter
why is it matt getz uh why isn't he
indicted yet
and why isn't why isn't this person
indicted why isn't that person indicted
if you look at really some of the people
who are involved in this and this list
of uh pocket pardons that is starting to
develop
it really does appear
that
the reason why department of justice is
acting
in a way that is very cautious and they
want to build a case
is because these people may have pocket
pardons they may have pardons that no
one else knows about besides donald
trump and them that was happened in
private they did it you know he wrote it
on a [ __ ] napkin or some [ __ ] from
mar-a-lago he's like this will do but
but we don't know if it will like and
the department of justice and these
prosecutors have no clue if that will be
validated through the courts so they
have to really make sure that they have
all their [ __ ] eyes dotted and their
t's crossed here and it's gonna take a
long time i think that's why it's taking
a long time for them to get to jeffrey
clark's house like it's taking a long
also there's this i even tweeted this
yesterday but like the the
and i was you know joking but i imagine
this is probably how it went down is
like matt gates was like look i i need a
blanket pardon the white house is like
for what and he's like everything just
[ __ ] everything right everything from
the beginning of time up until today for
any and all things and they're like
what why why would you need that right
right because of your defensive and
president's position and he's like
yeah let let's go with that you know and
they're like the [ __ ] you know and
meanwhile he's like i just got to
protect myself from the sex trafficking
it just it's insane to think that these
people who are like guys i'm innocent i
didn't do anything wrong these are all
baseless claims uh i'm totally cool and
you should totally vote for me back to
like back into office uh i didn't do
anything wrong but in the event that you
guys ever think i did something wrong i
kind of need to keep this one in my back
pocket in case a rainy day comes along
and somebody tries to search my [ __ ]
house and i pull out this get out of
jail free card right and say actually
guys
[ __ ] you can't do [ __ ] so that's why
it's so big that we have this um
this georgia state case right
investigation that's going against trump
because obviously
that's right right so you know then
that's where they're hoping he'll try
though don't you yeah yeah yeah yeah
he'll try to totally even though he
knows that's not how it works he'll try
it yeah
yeah it's it's it's insane so
uh
and here's the thing here's the thing
here's the craziest part of it there's
people gonna go to the polls in november
and vote for this [ __ ] oh yeah
oh my god how [ __ ] gross
the other thing is the other thing that
i i it is disgusting but the special uh
assistant uh to the president the um
hutchinson right i think is her name yes
yes yes the one that's sitting on the
couch right right yeah i think she's the
one that is gonna break this whole
[ __ ] thing apart i think she's like
sitting on a couch she's like look i
made it i made it a chore yeah
she's like oh yeah gilmer and scott
perry
but i like her when she starts like one
they already know
because like she even bring up marjory
taylor green they're like and did
marjorie taylor green ever ask you for
one which is like wait where did you
guys get that from like why are you guys
asking about her clearly
they clearly they know and you know
she was a congressperson for like three
[ __ ] days yeah january 3rd 2021 is
when she came into office so here we
have we have hudginson who's the the the
special assistant to the the president
so she's this middle person that's
getting all sorts of communication
coming through to you know meetings and
get this communication may get this
message whatever
and she's like uh they were like oh did
matt gates ever come out he's like yeah
like since like december many times i
don't know what for
like he just wanted to pardon and then
he's like she he kept he kept asking me
about the pardon
i don't know what he wanted it for you
know it's like we all know what he
wanted for but she's like i don't know
he just kept asking for it right like on
multiple occasions then you have jim
jordan who's like just want an update
can homer get an update on this i just
want to know what kind of congressional
party is right right
and and and she doesn't actually say he
was requesting one but he wanted to know
about him yeah so they knew they knew
that he was going to get a gauge on how
we're all feeling about this again
pardons we're not getting pardons right
not asking for myself necessarily just
want to get an overall sense
of if we just do
i want to observe crimes and not report
it
i'm jim jordan and i don't report crimes
when i observe them
i just want to observe them because i'm
which also
they're asking exactly what i mean based
on her account that she's telling right
now jim jordan coming in asking for an
update
kind of falls in line with the whole
fact that he's not able to remember any
point in time and or when he spoke to
donald trump on january 6. can't request
i imagine
that information is going to come out
soon enough because like i said in the
beginning of the show like
the questions have been prompted the the
topics have been brought up by the
committee
about these events
we they're not going to reveal the story
not until the very end potentially where
we get to the third act and we're like
just when you thought
[ __ ] was going nuts oh it's really going
to hit the fan and so now people are
inquisitive they're going to ask
questions journalists investigators are
going to look into this they're going to
poke around try to find out
they're giving the public
the the the crumbs you know like the
little sample for them to say oh you
know what this was delicious
i need the full meal on this bad boy i
need to buy it well here's here's part
of that delicious crumbs that we're
going to get from that documentary
because you know
you know that jared kushner the
testimony that we've seen from afar all
he can talk about is uh what was that
word it starts with a p pardons like he
literally is like all i was working on
was pardons i mean jesus christ we had
to pardon 140 members of the republican
party in the congress i wouldn't be
surprised and you shouldn't be surprised
that jared kushner was out there reeling
and dealing taking prices for what
people willing to pay for these parties
well and and we see
that what they were saying in testimony
is different than what they were saying
in the moment because we're going to get
this documentary footage which is
i i think it's going to crack this [ __ ]
wide open because there's a moment out
there with mike pence and i'm not going
to play it today but mike pence when he
receives some kind of notification about
the 25th amendment he's like ooh what's
this yeah he was like ooh yeah
print me out a hard copy for the ride
home right i want to i want to read this
on a sheet of paper please but here is
here brett put this uh video together
with midas touch
of ivanka under oath and when she's not
under oath in the documentary footage
let's let's watch this to see how
[ __ ] disgusting these people are
it affected my perspective um i respect
attorney general barr
um
so i
accepted what he said was saying as the
president has said
every single vote needs to be counted
and needs to be heard and he campaigned
for
the voiceless and i think a lot of
americans feel very very disenfranchised
right now
and
really question the sanctity of our
elections
and and that's not right it's not
acceptable and
um
he has to take on this fight and he
wants to make sure that that their voice
is is heard um and and muted and will
continue to fight um
until every legal remedy is exhausted
and and that's what he should do
that seems a little that those two
statements seem to be to contradict each
other i mean i'm gonna go with the fact
that these people
you know they love their ego they love
their image they're the trumps right you
know ivanka takes on that uh theranos cn
ceo kind of vibe where she like deepens
her voice and kind of needs to speak
like this with people respect me no one
respects you regardless of your voice
level and how your pitch is nobody
respects you not even the [ __ ] g20
summit people so
you look at this documentary and she's
there
trying to give this idea that the trumps
are great and we're giving a a voice to
the voiceless whatever the [ __ ] that
means
and
in this documentary they're clearly
taking this as an opportunity to create
an image of themselves right because
they're like oh a camera wants to come
in and say and i'm sure alex holder was
like look we want to make a documentary
about you guys now alex holder is the
filmmaker right right right right
filmmaker and i wanna and i wanna
imagine what he was saying was he came
in and was like hey we want to make a
documentary about you guys about this
successful great magnificent four years
as president
we want to bring the american people
inside
inside the white house of the great
american donald trump and they're like
you have me at great yeah and they're
like great awesome donald trump great
again like this exactly like that was
right that's probably all you had to say
oh look what's your pitch yeah
you said great
come on in let's do that and they set it
up and everyone agreed to it and i mean
it's the same reason like you know you
some people might have ulterior motives
for why they make documentaries but you
also might realize halfway through the
documentary that that's not the real
story in which you originally come into
but i'm sure alex holder already knew
what he was planning on doing he wanted
them to open up talk about everything
every [ __ ] thing that they would
mention because he was like i only got
so much time left and this [ __ ] house
is burning down to the [ __ ] ground
and i just want to get the footage of
them inside running around trying to
hide the fact that it is burning down
and speaking of footage we've seen is is
amazing so far well speaking of alex
holder because it goes right at one of
the bonehead of the weeks that we have
here because
i actually think it displays
uh how when you when you elect someone
who is a reality tv star
how we get reality tv government and
reality tv reality like it's just
absolutely [ __ ] bone ended [ __ ]
which brings us to the actual uh um bone
end of the week
i i'm gonna have to go back to the dm
and i want to do that but it brings us
to the bone of the week donald trump
because i want to get to this alex
holder thing but let's give donald trump
is due here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so your vote for donald trump for
bonehead of the week now it's changed
because and i'm leaving the dishonorable
mention because of what has happened
today and we're going to go to the
dishonorable mention after the winner
because i believe if they would have
voted this morning they would have voted
for the dishonorable mention gabe i
really want 100 100 but i want but i
want to show you this alex holder uh
he's actually on twitter here's alex
holder's twitter
um i'm not following him yet but i'm
going to right now just oh
um but here is um a statement that he's
giving for his subpoena for congress and
i'm not gonna read through it but he
basically says yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
give my footage my raw footage and i
think no this came out before the
hearing
on tuesday right
i i believe so now he's put it on his um
his twitter page but it requests it's
requesting the footage
from the interviews because to be clear
these are interviews that he was he was
conducting in a three-part documentary
series
about trump and his family and his
presidency right but there's the
statement there but this is uh here is
um
a tweet of some footage of donald trump
our winner and it says alex
says tweets himself he says it himself
the trumps did not have editorial
control full stop and the reason why
which proves my theory on he went in
knowing full well what he wanted to
[ __ ] do with this and got them to be
like oh yeah this is great every every
moment i'm sure that
despite his own like internal struggle
alex holder was like [ __ ] okay yeah
you're such a great person you're
amazing oh yeah you look great the tie's
a great color on you the complexion is
awesome you look amazing like just the
[ __ ] fluff that he has to give
to make sure that he gets the footage he
wants and it [ __ ] worked but here's
here's a bit of a
why how he's proving because this is the
reality star president more worried
more worried in this moment about how he
looks in this chair and how the table
looks than our democracy itself
wants this [ __ ] weird footage and it
just proves that
this guy
didn't
can release anything he wants from this
footage
and it's beautiful how he frames it up
here
you see [ __ ] sit down there okay
yeah mm-hmm
beautiful and you look you see him
looking up here right yeah he's looking
he's looking at the relay monitor that's
coming back right because because what
what he's looking at there's a tv that
is showing what the camera is showing
right because he and he's looking at his
shot now watch what he does about this
table here now we played this yesterday
and i used it as proof of what donald
trump he tries to get people to do
things
you know to try to make him try to make
him feel but but watch this
because he really gets upset about this
table
but this is just proof in this moment
because this is the thing that donald
trump doesn't want you to see that he's
a phony and a fraud that it's all
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's all faked up he
doesn't want you to see that that alex
holder's saying no this is proof that i
i can release whatever i want of this
footage oh
oh
oh i don't think i won't have the water
in the picture yeah no no you can take
it off you definitely don't want to
appear to not be able to drink water
there sir
oh my god
you know you know what's hilarious about
the drinking water thing and now that
we're on the water glass
everyone thinks it's because he has some
kind of cognitive disorder it's because
he wears so much makeup yeah he wears
and he doesn't he doesn't want it to
dribble down his face he won't do a
straw
right because that look it makes you
look like like he called mike pence a
[ __ ]
you know he thinks it makes you look
weak
so so he he makes himself look even more
weak because he doesn't want the the
makeup dribbles down but it's also like
oh oh and it's just you know the
relation of like going
right you know close to it which is like
oh it looks kind of looks something like
kind of like he's a wimp
well you know it makes him look like a
cuck but watch watch what he does at the
table here and and then and then we'll
go to the dishonorable mention because i
want to get to her because today's news
i want to get to her
kind of stable as well
yeah i might as well take the table
oh yeah
good very good thank you now what now i
know what you can do nick put the table
back
[Music]
put the table back and put the water on
the table without the thing on top of it
[Music]
so the thing on top is like a it's like
a coaster it's a it's a glass cover
right and then and then there's the
napkin underneath it and he didn't like
the look of the napkin in in the glass
cover yeah for the water but look at him
looking down like oh what am i going to
do if my water is not here for me it
also i mean like i will agree it does
look a little weird like there it looks
like there's a large open space now he
has nothing in him for like kind of
perspective so
i agree that the
i mean at least do you agree with you
agree with trump i agree with the
placement there but the idea that he's
like yes no okay the thing though is
he's so worried he is so worried
about that table more concerned about
that table than the rights of people oh
and the rights than democracy itself he
fundamentally does not understand that
the office that he hold that he held
what the power of it was and truly truly
that it was our office he just had the
privilege of presiding in it he truly
does not understand that he does not
someone else
who does not understand democracy i
believe
is susan collins she's our dishonorable
mention i'm leaving her for last because
of the decision that happened today gabe
tell us why you because you did this at
the very last moment yeah and it's
important to the decision that was made
by scotus i i some people i just quick
note some people were asking about alex
holder's twitter handle i just put it in
the chat so you can follow him there on
twitter uh i'm sure he'll he'll drop
more little snippets um
and we'll get more details as the the
hearings continue but the reason as i'm
sure everyone can imagine why i put
susan collins on the [ __ ]
dishonorable mention
is because of her clutching my pearls
and
they promised me as
as candidates or or nominees
uh uh gorsuch and kavanaugh
and and uh barrett they all promised me
they would not overturn roe v wade and
they said it was law of the land and
they guaranteed me
that they would not do anything to
disrupt because that is so important to
me
when everyone else is like dude do you
not notice they're [ __ ] crossing
their fingers behind their back right
now they're literally lying to your face
so that they can get them they can get
your vote
to become the next supreme court justice
and what happens
the leak comes uh you know not too long
ago
we find out that this is a potential of
being passed
and that today it does get overturned
and roe v wade is now you know it's its
future is now uh at risk or you know uh
for at least on the state rights level
and susan collins now is saying
oh maybe i should well she hasn't said
anything yet but i'm sure she's like oh
yeah well she'll be majorly concerned oh
yeah very very concerned
listen folks elections do have
consequences they and and it is no it is
no more displayed than this week with
the hearings that we have and the
decisions that are coming down from the
supreme court one that we're missing
highly is the separation between church
and state and the another one that is
that is totally not getting any uh
notice notice which is concerning is
about miranda rights and it just it just
speaks to elections have consequences
and what i mean by that is you have to
select your consequences because good or
bad they have consequences and the
consequences of the 2016 election for
people not engaging in that election was
to make sure that donald trump and the
fascist had the ability to try to take
over as much government as they possibly
could and we are we are now seeing the
ramifications of that this week
but in 2020 the elections had
consequences and the consequences of
that are playing out today as well on
the same stage where 15 republicans were
forced to vote for bare minimum bare
minimum gun safety regulations and now
the house is doing that again today
which will hopefully they'll take a vote
on the floor it'll get to the
president's desk and these regulations
can go into law but people
elections have consequences and every
single one of them this is the most
important election the one in front of
you because it has consequences and here
is why listen to what susan collins says
about brett kavanaugh i do not believe
that brett kavanaugh will overturn
presidents are overturned he noted that
roe had been reaffirmed 19 years later
by planned parenthood versus casey and
that it was precedent on president he
said it should be extremely rare that it
be overturned and it should be an
example you have obviously full
confidence i do we talked about whether
he considered road to be settled law
he said that he agreed with what justice
roberts said at his
nomination hearing in which he said that
it was settled law
i
could not vote for a judge who had
demonstrated hostility to roe v wade
because
it would indicate a lack of respect for
president
what judge kavanaugh told me and he's
the first supreme court nominee that
i've interviewed out of six who has told
me this is that he views precedent not
just as a legal doctrine but is rooted
in our constitution and he reveres our
constitution i asked him is it
sufficient if five current sitting
justices believe that roe should be
overturned and he said no
i would not support a nominee who
demonstrated hostility to roe v wade
because that would mean to me that their
judicial
philosophy did not include a respect for
established decisions judge kavanaugh
is the first supreme court nominee
to express the view
that precedent
is not merely a practice and tradition
but rooted
in article 3
of our constitution itself i will vote
to confirm
judge kavanaugh
so there you have it judge kavanaugh is
a [ __ ] liar and susan collins is a
[ __ ] bonehead thank you gabe
for the dishonorable mention because it
shows uh with susan collins standing
there at the very end lying lying either
lying to herself or lying to the senate
on official record that brett kavanaugh
was going to do something that he wasn't
going to do and she knew he wasn't going
to do it that elections have
consequences and the reason why i say
election have consequences folks is
because you have to engage we have to
engage with the ballot it is up to us
this decision today from the supreme
court to overturn roe v wade is just not
a front to a woman's uterus it is a
front to your daughters your sisters
your grandmothers and they're coming
after you they're not going to stop in
the red states they're going to continue
with the blue states they are going to
continue to to
to
at every single turn take away your
rights
jesus christ thomas says in the decision
gay marriage gay relationships same-sex
relationships even the contraception
they want to take away your right to
contraception on a federal level these
people are not going to stop that is
their mission that is their goal that
was the whole point of the whole god
damn thing so elections have
consequences folks and right now there's
only one party only one that is
interested in democracy and you must
vote accordingly and you must engage in
the ballot accordingly otherwise we get
more [ __ ] boneheads like this dumbass
yep
like the dishonorable mention that we
have today we get more boneheads like
this
making decisions for us on our behalf so
you must go vote do not let the
boneheads take over but for now for now
gabe that's the bone end of the week
stick around everybody we got a few
announcements right after the music
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign